we break necks all the title
it's kind of like the deer in the
headlights look when they see us because
it's unexpected
[Music]
a bunch of brown Indian boys walking
down Fifth Avenue in New York City and
killed since you don't see that every
day
[Music]
my name is too sharp Patel I'm the
backpack player and pipe major for
stream Oakland even starting up a pipe
band located at Shri Rama and temple and
Secaucus New Jersey
this Roman religion is a more modern
religion it's a sect of Hinduism that
promotes unity non-violence and peace
and well-being all throughout the world
music is definitely the fundamental of
our faith our spiritual leader shreemant
did you've inspired up a loved music he
fell in love with the sound of the
bagpipes so he instructed us to start
our own bagpipe band
[Music]
no one had any idea how to play bagpipe
music
[Music]
we found online videos internet videos
we bought a bunch of intro to bagpipe
books we didn't know any music but we
knew that if we work together if we were
unified that we can do anything the
sound of the bagpipes it's very similar
to some instruments that are found in
India while we're playing a Scottish
bagpipe we're still playing Indian music
as well as American music and music from
all around the world
being here in America we really wanted
to blend all the cultures that our band
represents we like to maintain that
traditional Scottish uniform but we also
like to blend in the Indian and American
culture that uniqueness is what defines
our band there's really a sense of pride
we're proud of each other and proud of
where we've grown it's not about only
just playing the bagpipes the reason
that we play is to continue spreading
our message of peace and unity through
music
[Music]